cette norme
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
chers amis de france inter
il se peut que cette chronique sur la
dernière
considérait la comme mon testament
ce matin à 6h30 à l'heure où fébus darde
encore ses rayons dans sa poche on a
sonné à ma porte
ça ne pouvait pas être le laitier je ne
boit pas de lait le matin ça fait cai et
la tequila de l'oeil
ça ne pouvait pas être le kgb je suis au
mieux avec moscou
j'ai rencontré l'autre jour un ingénieur
de tchernobyl qui ce désir adier dans la
piscine molitor
et je lui dis j'aime beaucoup ce que
vous faites
on sait jamais
on n'est jamais trop prudent
ça ne pouvait pas ça ne pouvait pas être
les les miliciens de pasqua j'aime
beaucoup parce quoi
ce look don camillo beurre alès je
résiste pas
il ya encore je lui ai téléphoné pour
lui cafter les agissements de ce connard
de jean claude bourret qui veut entrer
dans la résistance avec polak et denise
fabre pour la sauvegarde des services
publics
alors que fut ce cui celle qui donc
ébranlé m'ennuie
en fer est double beats étaient les
déménageurs
tout à mon sommeil dans les bras de
morphée et sous les genoux de la mère de
mes enfants présumés
j'avais oublié que je quittais ce matin
mon somptueux gourbis parisien pour
aller vivre désormais dans un minable
manoir de banlieue extrêmement sûr fait
c'est pas la peine de m'emmerder avec
l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes je fais
rien qu'à rétrogradé dans les ans
on est bien peu de chose mes frères en
pyjama rayé façon auschwitz fassassi
gros bras velus pétant de santé et armés
de sangles de cuir qui vous souffle à la
gueule par les naseaux béant de leurs
moufles ouvriers l'air encore frais du
matin frémissant de leur impatience à
vous casser la baraque
ils se sont engouffrés dans mes murs
comme si minotaure assoiffé de vengeance
mobilières et affamés de commodes louis
15 pardonnez-moi l'anachronisme j'aurais
dû dire de bahuts hercules
mais on n'a pas la sérénité d'andré
castelot devant son mal et isaac quand
on est piétiné à l'aube par une horde
d'hommes des bois de lits
par ou qu'on commence la musique le plus
féroce qui paraissait être le chef
les touffes de poils échappé de son
poitrail à l'affiché bausch et tous fait
le crocodile de son débardeur lacoste
signe distinctif du chef de meute chez
les tribus porteuse de piano à queue sur
la tête
commencez par vous voulez mais ne me
frappez pas monsieur s'il vous plaît et
je suppliais on lui [ __ ] les doit à
tout hasard pour apaiser son coup
en moins de temps qu'il n'en faut à
l'éjaculateur précoce pour prendre congé
d'ornellas mutti
il s'était répandu dans les étages en
rugissant les amants du tueur au des
terribles écumeurs de l'habitat urbain
urbain 6
le saint patron des balances heures
d'armoires par la fenêtre du troisième
je me précipitais en rampant sous la
moquette pour ne pas être connus vers la
chambre conjugale pour prévenir ma bien
aimée qui a le sommeil plus lourd que le
cul afin qu'elle trouve le temps de
s'échapper avant qu'il ne la folle avec
leurs gros bras de grizzly banlieusards
hélas il l'avait déjà roulé dans le
dessus de lit et jeté dans le monstrueux
camion noir de leur forfait impuni
je suis allé me réfugier dans mon bureau
en gravissant les escaliers sur la
pointe des pieds pour ne pas éveiller
l'attention de l'ennemi
à vrai dire j'avais l'impression de
gravir sur place
ces maudits [ __ ] avait déménagé
l'escalier
il ne me restait que les chiottes la
seule pièce de la maison qui ferme à
tacler ils n'iraient pas me chercher là
à l'heure où j'écris ces lignes il n'y a
plus un bruit dans la maison il est près
de 19 heures à ma montre je ne pense pas
qu'ils reviendront ce soir
je n'ose pas sortir
avant que le silence ne se fasse sur la
maison je n'ai entendu un pouce et à
travers les murs de pierre taillée un
son bestiaire qui m'a semblé reproduire
le ricanement typique du pithécanthrope
haineux de la section le pen dupré
quaternaire
on les finira demain matin
m'at-il semblé comprendre et je n'étais
évidemment pas en mesure de savoir s'il
parlait du déménagement ou de moi même
aussi bien dans le doute map stage
c'est pourquoi chers amis de france
inter au lieu d'enregistrer cette
émission comme à l'accoutumée dans un
chaleureux studios de radio france près
de la pulpeuse patricia martin
g mais aujourd'hui de se ré duit
obscures aux murs recouverts des
graffitis obscènes scabreux anodin ou
poétiques que j'ai moi même gravé au
feutre quand c'était le bon temps le
temps de l'insouciance le temps d'avant
les déménageurs
demain je quitterai la maison pour
toujours il ne m'en restera que ces
quelques pensées la scribouille et eilat
sur la la coque rouge blanc de ces
cabinets dont je reste le chef
l'est tandis que le crépuscule attend la
nuit pour étendre son grand manteau de
velours move préfontaine sur la ville et
sur les gens je relis à n'en plus finir
le mot terrible de talleyrand sur son
lit de mort à moins que ce ne soit un
mot de talleyrand sur le lit de mort de
la duchesse de montorgueil
mais qu'importe c'est un mot terrible
qui nous dit que
l'éternité c'est long surtout vers la
fin
quand assez féroce déménageurs je le dis
c'est pour vous cafter mais ils font
rien qu'à mûrir dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
canada
etonnant non
[Musique]